according to a wallet hub study 68
percent of women with children who are
under the age of 18 work thanks for
staying with us here at 6 30. i'm denise
valdez and i'm brian loftis and when it
comes to ranking states for working moms
nevada ranked 46 worse facts making up
that ranking include access to child
care professional opportunities and work
life balance sally jaramillo joins us
with more on why our state is ranked so
poorly
i spoke to some moms today who told me
the poor ranking doesn't surprise them
they also told me what they'd like to
see change when kovet hit i think us as
moms working moms had to kind of
rearrange a lot of things in life hannah
olivas is the ceo and founder of she
rice's studios a woman empowerment
publishing company in las vegas in los
angeles she started her business during
the pandemic as a mom what i struggled
the most with is having the distance
learning and having my nine-year-old
here while i'm trying to work olivas was
born and raised in las vegas she
believes it's challenging to be a
working mom in our state i don't think
we have enough resources
i also don't think our wages are
competitive to men oliva says add to
that we have a lot of families moving
here limiting resources we do need to
advocate for better
child care
better wages jessica peralta owns fit
for mom las vegas as a mother of four
she says this report doesn't surprise
her finding the balance of not only
trying to provide financially for your
family but also balancing out
all the roles and responsibilities that
comes with just being a mom right now is
of course moms that are trying to find
that balance and the limited resources
that are out there when it comes to
either child care options or flexibility
with jobs peralta adds while rebuilding
a business she is still trying to raise
her children and take care of their
needs is a daily challenge without a
doubt now among some of the best states
massachusetts connecticut rhode island
minnesota and wisconsin for a full list
of the report visit our website
eightnewsnow.com back to you